about 12 million Americans are dealing
with post-traumatic stress disorder it's
often the result of going through or
witnessing a life-threatening event like
War a natural disaster or an assault the
symptoms of PTSD like flashbacks and
heightened fear of danger can disrupt
daily life and contribute to long-term
health issues but many people with PTSD
are finding relief through a common form
of exercise Barry Peterson has the story
when you see Candace liger and Mariah
Rooney in a Denver area gym it's not a
run-of-the-mill workout they are
co-directors of trauma-informed
weightlifting teaching coaches how to
use weight training to help trauma
Survivor when you have experienced such
horrible things that tell you that maybe
you don't matter you're not strong that
you don't have the right to make choices
over your own body it's it's a pretty
powerful thing to then be able to move
in a way that really Taps into strength
if I can do this
I can control other parts of what's
Happening absolutely absolutely PTSD
causes elevated stress hormones often
trapping a person in fight or flight
mode exercises like this barbell back
squat might disrupt that doing something
like that could allow someone to just
focus on the movement and develop a
better connection to what their body is
doing in that mode is this a kind of a
message of
doing this exercise also means you're in
control as opposed to the things that
may have happened to you from outside of
your body in a lot of ways yes it can
feel like you're in control when you are
carrying weight or pushing weight or
pressing things or lifting things but
there is another message here about
holding weights behind you says Dr James
Whitworth of the Veterans Administration
Boston Health Care system and a
researcher on trauma and post-traumatic
stress disorder the benefit of that is
that you maybe feel fearful about what's
coming up behind you because of an
experience you had and this gives you a
sense of control or power over that
process is that a fairly good example of
why this weight training can help shift
how you feel about trauma and
post-traumatic stress I think that's a
good example Barry and using powerful
movements that make people feel strong
could be one of those benefits while
serving as a platoon sergeant in Iraq he
first connected exercise with trauma
therapy I would exercise with my fellow
soldiers to blow off steam to deal with
the stressors of combat but it wasn't
until I lost one of my friends and
Soldiers battle buddies to Suicide that
I really got interested in trauma PTSD
and how exercise might be helpful for
people suffering from ptfc now he's
focusing on weightlifting as a therapy
it's almost like seeing can reshape
believing seeing the growing muscle
helps in believing you have greater
Inner Strength it is an opportunity to
disrupt some of those cognitive
distortions and negative views of
themselves that may have risen as a
result of their trauma in a Philadelphia
Gym trainer Jessica Brock Pitts works
with Heather Dewar when you have trauma
you can get very disconnected from your
body and using strength training
movements to help get more in your body
and aware of how things feel in your
body and how these different Sensations
feel can be really helpful Heather
believes the results are helping resolve
her trauma I think that I'm on the way
for sure
gaining trust in my body giving
awareness of my body is laying a strong
Foundation towards resolution for me as
well probably about five six reps
Jessica teaches from her own experience
I am a survivor of trauma myself and
a person or kid so then I stumbled
across the trauma and formed
weightlifting training and was like oh
man this is for me the connection
between exercise and good health is
long-standing but using resistance
training as a coping strategy for PTSD
symptoms is still being studied and may
take a while to gain acceptance I'm
curious when you started looking at this
research and thinking about this did
your colleagues think you were just a
little crazy that's a a fun question but
I would say no so when you talk about
this at a dinner party people actually
take you seriously they don't like just
brush you off absolutely
in fact not brushed off but increasingly
available where coaches with specific
training can use heavy weights to
lighten the weight of trauma on a
person's soul for CBS Saturday morning
Barry Peterson Denver
Hey listen if it works I was just right
isn't it like whatever it takes and it
seems like the more stories we see and
the more we do it's each person that's
dealing with PTSD in different forms it
does take something different and that
handles it differently everything that
deals with it differently weight
training just overall is is a great form
of exercise and help of course with like
making you feel better about yourself
strengthen something within yeah there
you go right out